when I heard of the the building of
fiber to the home in Sweden the first
thing I thought of was finally I thought
this was a way for my dreams to come
through
haken Carson a motel defender cinema
come tomo turkish respect pacella
prepared asunto firm a nose insel avid
puedo contact of a textarea Makana fiber
optic a derivation vinos empathy lozano
destacar hacken lee decided to transform
a non-technical on studio demontage
realism of France ahead
now when I have the fiber to my doorstep
it's possible for me to live completely
another life than before I mean earlier
I spend 12 14 hours a day seven days a
week and during that time I don't see my
family that much that's for sure
sometimes i neva not in the same serious
to my family
Castle a high pop TKS on dezzy the park
avenue she be rockin Carson vote annuity
domoto heavily chanel betty jo kiya shon
system / made of a dermatologist owns a
big donkey caches Mickey
today I can work remotely with my
editing to earlier we had to fly
producers or directors from Berlin some
800 kilometres to Stockholm or from Oslo
some 450 kilometers 20 comm just to view
a version of a film and today through
the Hawkeye we can see the the streaming
video instead of attending or shipping
DVDs so we say it a lot of time and
thereby a lot of money and we also
protected the environment I don't think
I actually really left my editing room
when I worked in Stockholm and nowadays
yeah I have the nature close to my house
my office so I can have a walk by the
lake or somewhere and not actually
thinking about my job and things but
when I come back to the office i have
sold things during my walk I would say
hey thanks to the fiber to the home I
can end my Dame almost whenever I want
to I don't have to finish things before
I can go home I can just leave them go
home and make dinner with my family and
then hook up from my laptop at home and
continue wherever I were before
now the way I work today I'm more
efficient I can be wherever I want to be
and we can still do the same things now
my assistant can be in Stockholm which
is 250 kilometers from here and just log
into my computer or do things together
with me and help me out the support of
hawk which is 500 kilometers up north
can log in and help me out with problems
with the avid or something I could also
have collaborations with directors in
Stockholm or producers in Stockholm
the fiber to the home didn't made my
home closer it made my work closer